IVAN ZUZAK: Hey, everyone.
So I noticed on Moderator that
someone said, why do we have
testing and tooling
in the same panel?
So we will try to cover
both topics equally.
And with that, please join me
in welcoming Simon Stewart.
He works at Facebook, and he is
known for creating Selenium
and WebDriver.
Next to him is Remy Sharp, who
is the creator of JS Bin, JS
Console, and he curates the
Full Frontal conference.
David Blooman from BBC
News, who is the
testing superhero there.
And next to him is Paul Irish,
who is our opener.
He is a guru on the Chrome
Developer Relations team.
And he's also known for many,
many developer tools, such as
Modernizr, Yeoman, et
cetera, et cetera.
So I will invite Paul to give
an excellent introduction.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL IRISH: All right.
I'm going to go fast on this.
And I apologize, because I'm
speaking with an accent, for
probably most of you.
But we're going to go quick.
First, I'm going to give
a lay of the land
of the tooling ecosystem.
And then I'm going to give a few
demos showcasing some of
the cool stuff that's emerging
or things you might have not
seen in this area.
So first, it's hard to
conceptualize as far as all
the things that are captured
by tooling.
This is one approach--
Addy Osmani and I
worked on this--
kind of laying out a bunch of
the tools as far as the life
cycle of a project, from
boilerplate to abstractions,
the application stack, and then
into workflow performance
and builds.
But then we in the group here
were thinking about something
along these lines, too--
this is very much in
the tooling vein--
the package and dependency
management of my application
source code.
What my editing experience is
like, what the tools that the
browser actually provides is.
When it comes to testing, both
unit testing, integration
testing, CSS testing.
I'm going to show a demo
of some of that.
Then build and deployment, how
I'm automating browsers.
I'm probably going to be doing
that inside Continuous
Integration.
And then there's a lot
inside mobile.
So handling mobile devices,
whether they're local or in
the cloud, there's a lot.
So I want to dive into
a few things.
So CSS testing, this is a
fantastic slide deck and site
put together by Simon Madine.
This is focused on
four styles.
How can we better have
a feel for if we're
screwing up or not?
One of the projects that's
listed here--
a number of these are pretty
young projects, but this one,
called Fighting Layout Bugs,
has been around for about
three years.
And it's actually offered
in Java, mostly
for use with Maven.
And it does things like
these five tests here.
One of them is DetectTextNearOr
OverlappingVerticalEdge.
But what you'll end up
is this sort of test.
So it can actually detect when
you have text that's running
up against something
like an image or
even overflowing here.
And this is completely
automated, so on every commit,
Finding Layout Bugs is going to
make sure that you do not
have one of these problems
in your target browsers.
Pretty cool.
So you might be running this
inside Continuous Integration,
and I've seen a lot of movement
here recently.
Travis has kind of opened up
everyone's eyes in the open
source world, as far as
what can be done here.
This here is Travis running
the new Dojo 2 tests.
And so actually, Travis pulled
down the latest Dojo 2 source,
built out what it needed, and
then it connected up to Sauce
Labs, and opened up a bunch of
desktop and mobile browsers,
and ran the test suite of
Dojo 2 on all of them.
Reported back, and now for every
single commit and every
single pull request, we know
if we are looking good and
green or not.
Telemetry was mentioned
a little bit before.
And I just wanted to give a
better idea of what it does
and how it works.
Unfortunately, it requires a
check out of the Chromium code
base, which is about five gigs,
and I didn't want to
pull that down on the Wi-Fi.
So let me just talk it out.
Telemetry would take something
like this page.
Now, it's going to do something
like scroll the page
down, and it's going
to pop back up and
scroll it down again.
While it did those two things,
it's going to be extracting a
bunch of metrics from
the browser.
Like what was the paint rate?
How many million pixels per
second are being painted?
What was the FPS?
And now it's going to take all
these metrics and provide them
to me in a nice way.
And then I can take this and
plot it out against time or
against all my commits and
see, are my performance
thresholds being met
as the project is
growing and as it's living?
Or are me and my teammate adding
things to it that kill
the visual performance?
So there's a lot
of power here.
Another project from
the Chromium
team is called Endure.
This is something where you
can write a test like, OK,
open up Gmail, start
composing.
Now discard.
Start composing again.
Discard.
Repeat this for six hours.
Now tell me what's up.
So Endure will take this and
just handle the browser
automation for you.
And then it will give you back
some really fantastic insight
on the memory consumption of
this application over time
across a number of
different axes.
So you're able to understand
if you're increasing in an
uncontrollable way in your
memory situation.
All right.
Now, we've seen a lot of new
advancements when it comes to
mobile and cross-device
testing.
This was a project I bet a
number of you have seen called
Remote Preview, where I can
navigate to a URL here on my
machine, and all the browsers
follow my navigation.
Adobe Edge Inspect also has
a similar functionality.
And so it's cool.
I got all these phones right
here, and they're just
following me around.
It's pretty fantastic.
Mixture is another project.
Does some fantastic things.
It also does the same
thing, but on top of
this, it will add--
let's say there's a button.
I click it.
It pops up a dialogue, and
I close that dialogue.
Mixture will do the same stuff
but actually repeat those same
actions on all of these
devices as well.
So not just navigation but
actual click events so you can
see and verify that things are
occurring the way that you
would expect.
Now, I think it's cool to have
all this on devices that are
next to you.
But not everyone can afford all
the devices that you need
to actually support.
So we've been seeing things like
cloud browser testing.
BrowserStack is one I think most
people are familiar with.
And for mobile, they use
emulators, which is cool.
DeviceAnywhere actually features
real devices, which
is pretty cool.
It's a paid service, though.
They did just recently offer
this free service.
So I'm opening up
an iPhone 4S.
So this is actually a real
device, and I'm able to kind
of play around with it--
[INAUDIBLE]
Google News--
and click around.
I can also do--
let's see, I can mimic
a swipe and see that.
And you can see that the
performance here is actually
pretty good.
It's telling me that
my latency is OK.
And so this could actually even
get quite a bit better.
But it's pretty fantastic to
connect to an actual device
and get a better idea of
what my performance
situation is on that.
This is a project that is
totally alpha and has never
really been shown at all.
So I just want to FYI.
It's got some rough edges,
but it's pretty cool.
It's a project from some
engineers at Google.
It's called Tracing Framework.
And it's a bunch of analyses
for smoothness
inside of the browser.
And so the cool thing about it
is the instrumentation is
written completely in
JavaScript, which means it
runs in Chrome, Firefox,
IE, mobile
browsers, and web views.
So if you ever feel like you're
in a situation where
you do not have the browser
tooling to give you enough
insight in any of these
situations,
check out Tracing Framework.
Still, it's rough in alpha,
but it's worth a look.
Now, this conversation wouldn't
be complete without
talking about the dev tools
that are in the browser.
And I wanted to show
a few things.
The first up is Canvas
Inspection.
And the cool thing is we've
never showed this before.
And it's coming out.
It's still kind of
an experiment.
But I'm excited to show it.
So I brought up here this
WebGL Aquarium.
It's pretty cool.
Now, when we're in Profiles, we
see Capture Canvas Frame.
But I actually need to have the
dev tools open while this
canvas is created.
Now I'm going to capture
that frame.
And up here, it looks like we
captured it at 4,300 calls to
the context.
And these are all the calls that
were made that changed
the context.
And I can step through
all of them.
And what it's going to do is
it's going to replay all the
calls up to this point.
And I can set through
all the draw calls.
Let's see.
Give me some fishes.
Fishes!
Fish, fish.
Yeah, good.
Great.
Fishes.
So we're able to see
step-by-step as this frame is
being constructed and correlate
that back to my
actual code of what
was happening.
So I can click over there and
see this, in fact, was making
these draw calls.
Now, I don't know if you guys
noticed this, but when I
actually clicked from Profiles
over into the Sources panel,
there was a little
bit of a delay.
Now, let's say I actually want
to figure out why there's such
a delay there.
So first, I'm going to undock
this move over that guy, and I
think you see what's happening
here is that I'm using the dev
tools on the dev tools.
I'm going to start a new
timeline, and I'm going to
repeat this action.
And there we go, capture that.
So inside the timeline, we're
getting some good information
on how long things like
paints, recalc
styles are all taking.
And over here on the left-hand
side, we can see this yellow.
And this is my click event.
And we can see that it
was pretty long.
In this case, it
took almost 400
milliseconds to complete that.
Now why was that?
Eesh.
So you look over here, and you
see this is what happened
inside that time.
We got a lot of Recalculate
Style and Layout, and Recalc
Style, Layout.
And this is what we were talking
about before when we
were talking about excess
reflows, layout thrashing.
Layout and reflow are the same
thing across browsers.
But this is a bad situation.
This is a pattern you
want to avoid.
And the cool thing here
is the dev tools are
actually telling you this.
There's a little indicator that
says you might have a
problem. "Forced synchronous
layer is a possible
performance bottleneck." And
the fact that we're seeing
this nonstop back and forth
means there's probably an
ability to optimize.
So Pavel, you should
probably optimize
this in the dev tools.
Sounds good.
All right.
So a lot of times, there is
a problem with paint.
Paint is consuming a lot of
time, and it's a little hard
to get a feel for
what's going on.
So earlier in some talks, they
brought up continuous page
repainting, and I want to show
what that looks like.
Let's try this guy.
Yeah, cool.
All right, bringing back the dev
tools, I'm going to dock
them again.
And over here in the settings,
I'm going to turn on
continuous page repainting.
So up here, we get an idea of
how long it's taking to paint
this page right here.
So let's say right now it's
taking about 15 milliseconds.
But first, I'm going to go over
here, and I'm going to
turn off some of the styles.
So on each of these little
Chrome logos, I got a box
shadow and a border radius.
I'm going to clear those off.
And my paint time jumps
down, which is good.
It's much cheaper to
paint this page.
Now, the interesting thing here
is that because I have
this live feedback and kind of
play around, I can see what is
contributing to long paints.
So if I add on border radius,
you can see it jumped up from
about twos and threes up
to the fours and fives.
Cool.
Take that off and put on box
shadow, which is normally kind
of expensive, you hear.
But my paint time is actually
pretty reasonable.
But check this out.
I add both of them--
ooh--
and my paint time just
went up to about 20
milliseconds per frame.
And so I get great feedback
here on what is actually
contributing.
It turns out that by themselves,
these styles,
they're pretty cheap.
But in combination, the browser
takes a little bit of
time on it.
Now, painting can be expensive,
and there's a lot
that could be done.
And I wanted to show one thing
that has been done recently.
So--
cool.
This right here is Chrome
for Android stable.
And so we have an article
on HTML5 Rocks.
And now what I'm going to do
is just scroll the page.
Scroll.
There we go.
Cool.
And you see I'm scrolling down,
and the browser kind of
catches up.
But for a little while,
the page is blank.
And then it comes in.
So it's probably not optimal.
We just added a new thing to
Chrome on Android called
multi-threaded painting.
And so here--
so this is Chrome for
Android beta.
You can get this from
Google Play.
Now if I scroll, I think you
see that there's no white.
That's cool.
Another thing--
you might be able to see it--
is the text actually gets a
little blurry when this
is going too fast.
And we have low-res tiles that
are in place just in case
you're moving really, really
fast, that it will resolve to
the crisp picture that
you're looking for.
So this actual painting is
happening on a separate
thread, which is pretty cool,
one, for the performance
benefit, but two, for speed.
Over here, this is
about tracing.
I think this has been mentioned
before as well.
Here, we get kind of--
I mean, this looks
intimidating.
And it is, but there's good
ways to read these things.
So right now, I'm zooming in
on the RendererMain thread.
This is the UI thread.
This is the "don't block
this thread" thread.
There's a lot of other parts
in the browser, like the
compositor up here, but I'm
going to jump in to this guy
and zoom in.
And down here, we've
got a few things.
V8.callFunction.
This is JavaScript.
JavaScript is running
right now.
And then, all of a sudden,
we hit Picture Record.
So this is a capture from Chrome
Canary on desktop doing
multi-threaded painting.
And this Picture Record is
actually recording all the
draw calls that are coming
into Chrome.
And Chrome is like, OK, I've
got all these draws.
Here they are.
I'm going to pass it up
to the compositor.
The compositors are like, cool,
I'm going to spawn off a
new thread that's
CompositorWorker, and he's
going to take care
of this for you.
So CompositorWorker right here,
he's doing the paint.
This paint raster right here
is the actual paints.
And what this means is because
this is on a separate thread,
I can now be executing
JavaScript at the same time.
So here we are in v8, executing
JavaScript at the
same time as I'm doing paints.
We haven't been able to do
this before, but now it's
finally happening.
I'm really excited about that.
All right, the last thing I just
want to mention is I'm
not going to demo Remote
Debugging, but everything that
I showed is available, just
the same thing, just
connecting on here.
Really fantastic, because the
performance characteristics on
a device with hardware that is
so different as a laptop is
something that you really want
to be very mindful of as
you're developing all
these experiences.
Lastly, a few trends I think
I've been witnessing and will
continue in 2013.
We're seeing a rise of people
leveraging Continuous
Integration, not just for
running things like unit tests
but also making sure that
there's no performance
regressions as the project
is built out.
Things like people are focusing
on a better mobile
debugging workflow and making
sure that for throwing tests
on there, getting tests out of
it, and seeing their work,
that everything is working
very nicely.
A bigger adoption of using
dependency management, not
just for third-party libraries
but also for your own
application code, and people
being very mindful of
performance from the beginning
of the project so that a
project can sail nicely from
these devices to these
devices, and all your
users are happy.
That's it for this little
opener, and let's
get into the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN ZUZAK: That's awesome.
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: I do.
IVAN ZUZAK: OK, that's
all we have as intro.
So there is, like, 30 questions
on Moderator--
33.
And let's just try to
get as much through.
So the first question that
[INAUDIBLE], also from Google
Chrome Developer Relations put
on Moderator was, mobile is a
big focus for developers
this year.
So what do you see as being the
biggest pain points in the
mobile test--
mobile tooling landscape?
And I think everyone can just
chip in what they think.
So let's start from Remy.
REMY SHARP: The other browsers
is the big pain point for me
at the moment.
The fact that I've got Dev Tools
on Android is amazing.
But then I have to use Safari,
and that's horrible for me.
And that has kind of
set me up to--
I've started a project
in my company--
very, very early days-- where
I'm trying to get the point,
ultimately, to just use Dev
Tools to debug every single
mobile platform--
Safari, Firefox, Opera, Chrome,
Windows, all of them--
using the debugger protocol.
And it's not so much of an
automation tool, and it's
having the hardware there but
using just Dev Tools to go in
and do that micro debugging, but
have one familiar tool and
just debug the other tools.
I hate working with Safari's
remote debugger.
It's great that we've got it,
but I really, really struggle
with the tool.
So the pain point, for me, is
it just kind of exposes how
bad the other dev tools are.
IE 10 mobile, that's
a great browser.
But where are the dev tools?
SIMON STEWART: OK.
So the desktop world was
surprisingly simple, entirely
by accident.
But it was surprisingly
simple.
We only had web apps running
in a browser,
and that was fine.
The mobile world, because the
devices are underpowered, and
they're a little bit puny, and
Moore's Law is helping, but
they are improving.
The apps we get when we need
to test aren't just
running in a browser.
They're running in web views
contained within the native
application.
And you need to be able to test
the communication between
the native part of the app in
the web part of the app, and
the web part in the
native part.
And who knows, right?
It's a complete nightmare.
So not only do we have a more
complex testing environment to
begin with, the tooling
just isn't there.
It's still early days.
There are very few tools out
there that can actually be
used to test a hybrid
application successfully and
in a way that won't cause your
developers to scream at you in
just pure rage and
frustration.
We'll get there one day, but
that's the main pain point,
just that the tooling
isn't there.
DAVID BLOOMAN: Yeah, similar
to Remy, but [INAUDIBLE].
I don't like Safari at all,
so I don't use it.
But the generic Web Inspector
Remote has been quite
successful, quite
useful for me.
But that's only for
WebKit browsers.
But what about everything
else?
And things like BlackBerrys,
which are still very high
usage and something like News
is very difficult to do
anything with.
And then automations, iOS and
Android are pretty much the
only two platforms.
So you're stuck with them.
Even the new platforms, like
BlackBerry, how do you even
approach them with no tools?
You can't do much with them.
So there's a lot lacking.
And hopefully, some nice people
will come along and
build something new, and
the tools will mature.
But there are still the legacy
browsers and operating systems
that we're going to have to
deal with for a long time.
So tooling is going to get
better, but it's also going to
stay bad at the same time.
PAUL IRISH: I would say one part
of this is that I think a
lot of developers' workflow for
their mobile testing is
extremely manual.
It is a matter of putting up the
newest version on stage,
hitting Refresh, seeing,
exploring, then going to the
next device that has the
viewport that they care about,
and hitting Refresh,
testing that.
And I think it's just
really slow.
And there's a lot of existing
solutions that can totally
improve that.
And I think that's worth
looking into.
The other part that I think is
important-- and I mentioned
this in the opening, which is
that I don't think every
developer can afford all the
devices that they need to be
testing on.
I mean, the Remote Debugging
capability that we're seeing
is very important when you
have the device there.
But I do think that
having access to--
being able to run your
application in these mobile
devices that you don't actually
own is really important.
So I'm looking forward to seeing
how we can solve that.
Yeah.
IVAN ZUZAK: Great OK,
so let's continue.
The question is, what are
currently the best tools and
workflows for testing and
debugging mobile devices?
And I think David
can start this.
DAVID BLOOMAN: Yeah,
so I've tried to--
in my role at the BBC, tried to
just use as many tools as I
can, really, to get the best
out of all our devices.
But as you said, it's a
very manual process
a lot of the time.
But we've implemented, recently,
the CSS Regression
Testing, which internally we
call a "snappy snaps." So it
will capture two images
of two domains.
So we use a stage and a live
environment, every
[? resolution ?] we really want,
and then various asset
types, so front page and story
pages, and then compare them
using ImageMagick to output a
[? DIF ?] image, which you can
then review.
So you can test a massive amount
of pages of different
resolutions very quickly and
identify the differences and
then collaboratively decide
how you want to
move on from there.
So there are tools like that
that really just cut down the
amount of manual testing you can
do, because you can just
automate a lot of it.
ImageMagick is a very powerful
tool, so you can use
percentage differences,
as well.
So it's just a series of numbers
that come out, and you
know whether you've got
huge CSS regressions.
And again, tools like Web
Inspector Remote and Remote
Debugging on Android, especially
of picking up
networking things, like are we
making sure that stats are
being recorded over the Chrome
Dev Tools is so important.
And using those tools has been
really beneficial for us.
There are other tools, like
Remote Preview and Adobe
Shadow, which you can use.
But the things is that Adobe
Shadow or Edge Inspect is a
costly one.
And I think that's where the
cost element is quite
difficult in mobile
[? responsive ?]
because you need all the devices
in a lot of cases, and
financially, it's impossible to
have for an independent or
small company.
BrowserStack is a good option.
And I haven't really looked into
TestPlant, but it's an
option as well.
But there are some good tools.
I think if you're interested,
there's a great amount of
tools on RGA Online, a site
which will point you in the
right direction.
IVAN ZUZAK: Great.
Simon, what can you tell
us about WebDriver?
SIMON STEWART: Yeah,
WebDriver.
So tools for doing testing
on mobile.
The first thing I was going to
suggest was it isn't that
different from being on
the desktop, right?
So you could use all the
JavaScript frameworks that are
already out there, things like
Jasmine, for example, if
you're a BDD fan, still work
in a mobile browser.
And a mobile browser nowadays
runs on a device that has the
same power as the old G5 Macs
that people used to do their
development on.
We think of them as underpowered
devices.
They're enormously
capable, and they
keep on getting faster.
So you could keep
on doing that.
I obviously have a
vested interest.
I am the lead of the
Selenium project.
I invented WebDriver.
We're standardizing
that with the W3C.
Hopefully, the best way to test
mobile browsers will be
to use the WebDriver APIs, which
will enable you to do
all sorts of fun things,
particularly from the point of
view of automating a browser
from a user's perspective.
Go to this page, click on this
link, execute this piece of
JavaScript.
Now let me see what the text is
on the page as a user would
see it, which is an enormously
powerful thing to do.
And I've been on projects
where we've had those
end-to-end tests, smaller
integration tests, unit tests,
realize that we've made some
fundamental failures in the
architecture of the application,
thrown away every
test apart from the WebDriver
tests, and rebuilt everything
just using those.
So if you write them well,
they can work.
If I was going to name
frameworks, obviously Selenium
is probably one that I
would rush out and
download right now.
I'm biased, though,
so that's OK.
For mobile, it might be worth
having a look at a thing
called iOS Driver, which is
written by Francois Reynaud,
who is working at eBay.
And Sauce Labs recently put a
lot of weight behind a project
called Appium.
So if you go to saucelabs.com
and take a look for Appium on
their site, you'll be
able to find it.
Both of those are for iOS.
And they allow you to test
native apps, hybrid apps, and
just plain web apps, as well.
So that's pretty cool.
On the Android platform, I think
it's still fair game.
There will be something that
uses UI automation.
And there's going to be a period
of about a year, two
years, while people
go, what about the
older versions of Android?
They're still really popular.
And then people will realize
that it's a pain in the
backside to test those things.
And time will be on our side,
and hopefully, we'll only have
ICS and above in about 50 years
of something, in the way
that Android is updating.
But it'll happen eventually,
and that will
be extremely cool.
IVAN ZUZAK: Want to add
something, Remy?
REMY SHARP: Yeah, I'm
more in the kind of
debugging end of things.
So actually, for a project that
we are releasing for a
client literally Friday, we're
trying to get the last style
changes in.
And we've got this iPad Mini,
and what I ended up doing was
using Dev Tools in Chrome,
having it save as I was making
changes to the local disk, and
then I had LiveReload just
sitting on there.
And the UX guy was sat next
to me with the iPad.
And he was like, OK, just
tweak this color.
I'd tweak it on my desktop.
And in the inspector, I'm
changing the color and
releasing, and it's immediately
on the iPad Mini.
Which for me, getting away
from coding, saving,
switching, hitting Refresh,
going to the device, hitting
Refresh, that's where I
live at the moment.
And the closer I get to actually
using the browser as
my development--
an IDE by IDE--
the happier I get.
And I'm really impatient.
I want that feedback.
I want to know now.
And I want it all reloading
live, and my workflow is
getting really, really
close to that.
And I see some of my guys
working, using--
in JS Bin, we've got a remote
rendering feature in it so you
can code away, and it will just
automatically update on
the device.
And I see them actually using
that as well, which is really
cool for me.
But yeah, basically, immediacy,
that's what
[INAUDIBLE].
IVAN ZUZAK: So there's this
question from Addy again.
And he says, seeing browser
developer tools flourish into
fully blown editors
is very exciting.
And at what point should we stop
pushing the envelope and
suggest developers use
their own tools?
So do you think that will
happen, or will we push the
envelope far and beyond and
use browser dev tools for
everything?
REMY SHARP: For me, personally,
I'm much more
towards the end of using the
browser as close as--
I want to get the output, the
rendered page, and what I'm
typing as close as possible.
I'm typing, I want to see
the output immediately.
If it lives inside of the
IDE itself, then fine.
But at the moment.
Dev Tools is kind of ticking
that box for me.
IVAN ZUZAK: So are there any
key parts that are missing
from dev tools currently for
any browser for you?
REMY SHARP: The testing,
for me.
Event proxying--
that's something I mentioned.
SIMON STEWART: That's
in WebDriver.
REMY SHARP: What's that?
SIMON STEWART: WebDriver's
got that.
REMY SHARP: I haven't
seen WebDriver.
SIMON STEWART: It's being
standardized.
REMY SHARP: So one thing that's
missing for me is I
don't want to type in a lat-long
to be able to emulate
geolocation.
I want my phone to
give it to me.
The accelerometer, I
want that to feed
straight into the desktop.
I know Paul and Addy
have hinted at, or
might mention something.
PAUL IRISH: There's likely going
to be some more stuff
that would make Remy happy, as
far as developing in the
browser more.
And actually, to add on to a
little bit of the mobile tools
and workflows, we talked a lot
about what are the ways to
work with these devices.
But the other thing is that a
lot of times, you can end up
doing a lot of development just
on desktop, straight up.
Firefox has a fantastic,
responsive design tool built
into their dev tools now.
Inside Chrome, there's
device metrics.
And there's, like, 50
different sites and
bookmarklets to get various
different iframes so they can
test your viewport
for any site.
But things like emulating touch
events, emulating and
spoofing geolocation,
these are all in the
browser now, too.
So there's a good amount that
you can get away with on
desktop before you go to the
device to make sure that your
performance goals are
being met, too.
So I'd add that in.
SIMON STEWART: Right.
So I think one of the things
we're missing here are the
audiences for testing, right?
Your workflow sounds very
developer-centric, like you
want to make sure that the CSS
and the UX is perfect.
The people that tend to use
WebDriver tend to be more
interested in the end-to-end
testing and the functionality
of the application, particularly
as a workflow or
a walkthrough goes.
So I probably wouldn't recommend
end-to-end testers
use dev tools, because it's
not the right hammer to be
hitting this particular
nail with.
And it's got to be like take
a look at what people are
actually attempting to do and
their relative skill levels
and try and figure out what
the best approach is.
For a handful of people, being
in the dev tools and being
highly technical and getting
all the metrics out of the
browser is entirely the
right thing to do.
And that's a fantastic option
for those people.
But for hundreds of people, for
a majority of developers,
actually, it's enough to be
able to throw something
together with a bit of Python
or a small amount of
JavaScript and use that to
verify that the application is
doing what it's meant
to be doing.
So yeah, think about the
audience of who's going to be
using this and how they're going
to be using it and how
they're going to be integrating
with the team.
And it may turn out that
actually, not being in the
browser is a better way
of going about it.
And sometimes, it's
going to be better
to do things manually.
"Does this feel right" is a
really hard question for
machine to answer but a
really easy question
for a person to answer.
REMY SHARP: Can I just tack
on to the end of that?
I can't remember who the
conversations were with, but
I've got a feeling it might
be Paul, like a year ago.
Web developers don't jump on
to the command line as
frequently as a Python developer
or a Ruby developer.
I'm comfortable with
the command line.
But out of the web developers
here, you probably do
server-side coding, anyway.
But hands up who's pretty
comfortable using the command
line or coding up--
actually, this is a bit
of a [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
REMY SHARP: It's a technical
audience in the first place.
Loaded question, bias,
so on and so forth.
But there's that question
as well.
IVAN ZUZAK: So it seems like
having a huge number of mobile
devices is the only way to
reliably test on Android and
BlackBerry.
Is there any hope of having
accurate, reliable emulators
for platforms other than iOS?
REMY SHARP: I would add iOS
to that list as well.
IVAN ZUZAK: Yeah?
Anyone?
So is there any hope for having
really reliable emulators?
SIMON STEWART: No.
IVAN ZUZAK: Excellent.
REMY SHARP: Just to
give Opera props,
isn't the Opera emulator--
isn't it supposed to
be exactly the
same as Opera Mobile?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
backed up.
But it obviously doesn't have
the same [INAUDIBLE]
device.
AUDIENCE: WebOS is
pretty good.
IVAN ZUZAK: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: WebOS is
pretty good.
PAUL IRISH: WebOS.
Yeah, I think you could say
that there is hope that
they'll get better.
I would expect those
vendors to put
support into those tools.
So yeah.
SIMON STEWART: Great.
More optimistically than
just a flat no.
I think the Pareto principle
is going to kick in here--
the 80-20 rule.
Testing on a simulator and
emulator is going to be fairly
close, and in the common case,
actually enough for our
testing needs.
But there's always going to
be some weird quirk in the
hardware that we're going
to need the devices for.
So are the emulators going to
get enough where it'll move
away from the 80-20
to 90-10 or 95-5?
I don't know.
But having seen the progress of
the Android emulator, which
has gone from being quite
painful to use to actually
being good enough to do a
majority of my testing on,
particularly with the Intel
version that's available now,
yeah, I'm actually relatively
hopeful about hitting the
90-10 point.
IVAN ZUZAK: Excellent.
REMY SHARP: There's a
question over back.
AUDIENCE: I just want to
give a shout out to
opendevicelab.com, which is
actually opening device labs
all over the world right now.
They've got 40 locations.
One of them is a
Mozilla office.
Google is thinking about it.
So if you've got hardware you
don't use, you can donate it
to one of them, and every
developer can go there and try
on real devices to play
with their things.
Because we can make emulators
as much as we want.
Most of the errors come through
touching and playing
with the thing on the
real hardware.
When I put Firefox OS on SIIs,
three devices, same device,
completely different results.
So it's not that easy.
But OpenDeviceLab is a really,
really good idea for people
that can't afford all these
phones to actually play with
them in an office that
is a sharing space.
And there's lots and lots
of them worldwide.
So just wanted to
mention that.
PAUL IRISH: They also have a lot
of information for people
that want to set up their own
device labs, too, and
community support for that.
DAVID BLOOMAN: I also, if I'm
passing a phone shop, I'll
just go in and have a play,
see what's going on.
And I recommend you do, too,
because the important thing to
know is what's in a shop
is what somebody could
potentially be using to
access your site.
So that's a great idea
of what exactly is
going on in the market.
And obviously, it's going to be
market specific, but you'd
be surprised at some of the
travesties that are in phone
shops nowadays.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Really quick, it's
worth pointing out that most
of the emulator execution is
somewhere else in the stack.
There's a great company
called [INAUDIBLE]
Incorporated, which has proven
that they can run ARM code on
x86 faster than ARM
executes on ARM.
So obviously, the problem isn't
with the ARM device or
the instruction set.
It's somewhere in the
stack to get these
emulators up and running.
Most of the time, it's a balance
between the teams
trying to get their products
out the door
versus actually caring--
or to put it in correct
terminology, since we're about
to have beers-- giving enough
shits about getting their
emulators up and running.
So if this is something that
matters to web dev as a whole,
you should definitely be putting
more pressure on these
manufacturers to get
their emulators up
to speed to do things.
IVAN ZUZAK: Excellent.
Great.
So let's switch gears a bit.
Here's one of my questions.
Will we get a solution for
package management and module
loading soon?
There have been several tools
that have shown that it could
be done, but there's
no real consensus.
And will ECMAScript 6
modules solve this?
And Addy corrected me.
So these are actually two
questions in one.
And package management
is somewhat
separate from module loading.
So this is a real problem
for a lot of developers.
And Paul, perhaps you
can start this.
PAUL IRISH: Sure.
So right now in client-side
package management, there's a
few possibilities.
A while ago, there was a project
called Ender, and the
people who made Ender decided
that it didn't really work
out, so that's mostly dead.
There's also volo, made by
James Burke, who created
Require.js, which
is pretty cool.
Bower, originally released by
Twitter, and there's also a
lot of folks using NPM, sending
it through Browserify,
and getting it to work there.
And these are all kind of
using different registry
approaches, different ideas on,
should we start an entire
new JavaScript library ecosystem
from scratch or use
one that's already available?
Do we just accept that we can
use node packages inside the
browser and make that work?
And it's kind of messy
right now.
I mean, I'm most excited about
what's happening with the
Bower project.
It has about 900 packages
in it, all working.
Dependency resolution
works fantastic.
You actually get updated inside
the UI when JavaScript
library ships a new version.
So it kind of keeps
you up to date.
But there's a lot of challenges,
because package
management for client side is
something where it's useful
when it hits a critical mass.
And I don't think
we're there yet.
So I'm looking forward to seeing
what we can do, either
inside this tool or another
tool, to kind of get there.
Because without package
management client side,
everyone's going to be afraid of
calling jQuery dependency.
And jQuery is already too big.
So it could have been smaller
had we had proper package
management.
And I think it would really open
up a lot of progress and
forward momentum in what we're
able to get away with on the
front end when we can actually
create reasonable
dependencies.
IVAN ZUZAK: So there's this
point where at one point,
standardization should
come in?
PAUL IRISH: Alex?
You want to talk about
ESX modules?
ALEX RUSSELL: Sure.
So I'm Alex Russell, Google, one
of our representatives on
TC39, the standards body
for JavaScript.
So there is a module system
coming in the next version of
JavaScript.
Will you be able to use it on
all the devices that are
deployed today?
Well, that depends on whether
or not you're
targeting new browsers.
So the answer is no.
At least no in the short term.
In the long term--
well, in the intermediary time,
you'll be able to use
tools like Tracer and
other transpilers--
JavaScript to JavaScript
compilers--
that will allow you to sort of
program in the source language
and then convert to the other
one, based on a standard
syntax, which sort of sets you
up for living in the wonderful
future that will eventually
arrive.
So that's a strategy that
you can use today.
There's a little bit of tension
right now in the
committee about what's going to
happen with the particulars
of the syntax and some
of the semantics.
And we're ironing
those out now.
But the goal for us is to have a
version of the language that
has this done, more or less
feature complete, by the end
of the year.
So wish us luck.
And I guess if you'd like to
start using what is likely to
become the module system for the
next version of ECMAScript
today, it's not a
package manager.
It's just a module system.
But you can check out Tracer
and a couple of other
transpilers that are starting
to support it.
IVAN ZUZAK: Good.
So while you have the
mic, I want to
ask you another question.
So what should be the role
of standardization in web
development during testing, and
what are some of the areas
that would benefit from
standardization right now?
ALEX RUSSELL: OK, so with my
non-Google hat on, with my W3C
TAG member hat on, let me answer
the question in terms
of, what's the role of
a standards body.
My view is that the role of a
standards body-- and this is
not the TAG's view, but it's my
personal view-- is that the
role of a standards body is to
hold the coats while everybody
gets yelled at to go have a
fight inside of a ring, right?
They set the rules, and they
hold the coats while people
duke it out inside some
preordained boxing ring.
And they aren't let out again
until users have one answer.
The goal here is to get users
to say, holy cow, you guys
have made this really hard.
You might all have some answer,
but we need one
standard answer.
And that usually only happens
when A, everybody understands
the problem.
So until everybody understands
the problem, if there's some
vocal minority that says,
look, there's this giant
problem, well, that's probably
not enough to get a standards
effort to a successful
conclusion.
So if everyone understands the
problem, and there are
competing answers, that's sort
of the predicate for a
successful standards scrum.
You can't really start the
game until those set of
conditions have been met.
So it's good for browser vendors
to innovate, to start
working together to
collaboratively look at what's
happening inside the world.
What are the libraries doing?
What are the compilers doing?
Where are we falling
down on the job?
Where are users yelling
at us most loudly?
And once that happens, go to
the standards body and say,
OK, well, this is the subset of
what we clearly understand
is a relatively good answer.
Let's standardize that.
And then to hopefully integrate
more of what is then
collectively understood to be
the right problem or the right
answer as time passes.
IVAN ZUZAK: OK, thanks.
Simon.
What's your experience from
being on W3C group for testing
and tooling?
SIMON STEWART: Yeah, so
WebDriver is in a really
interesting space in that it's a
de facto standard that we're
turning into a de
jure standard.
A lot of the tools that Paul
was talking about earlier,
anything that connects to
Sauce Labs is using the
WebDriver APIs.
Michael Tamm's Fighting Layout
Bugs, that uses WebDriver.
It keeps on cropping up in these
sort of unusual places.
The Appium stuff, that
uses the wire
protocol from WebDriver.
And so yeah, what we're
attempting to do right now is
go, what we need is--
that work is currently being
done by a relatively small
open source team.
And they're brilliant.
They are an amazing team.
But we're now at the point,
and we're past the point,
where in order to make the
things that people want to be
able to test work properly, we
need the aid and help of the
people writing the browsers.
We need to be baked
into the browsers.
Opera were the first people that
stepped up to the plate
and went, you know what?
We could actually do this.
And the Opera driver was a
fantastic step forward and was
incredibly fast and
incredibly stable.
Chrome followed relatively
swiftly after that.
And we went from having a fairly
buggy, painful to use
Chrome driver to something
that was amazing.
Mozilla, we talk about
M-Day on the project.
Mozilla have a project called
Marionette, which is their
implementation of the
WebDriver APIs.
So my experience has been
actually really, really
positive, like everybody sees
the need for these things.
Everyone is pulling together,
and we're all just trying to
figure out the nicest way of
standardizing these things.
REMY SHARP: Is Microsoft
on that list?
SIMON STEWART: So yes,
Microsoft, Apple.
There are now representatives
from Microsoft on the working
group mailing list, and I think
they're planning on
showing up to the next
face-to-face session.
There were Microsoft
representatives at TPAC last
year, in 2012, as well, who
attended a full day of
discussion.
So actually, Microsoft,
obviously they don't tell us
everything.
But they are taking
it seriously.
Apple are Apple, and nobody
knows quite what's going to
happen there.
But I think it's inevitable.
I really hope it's inevitable,
because everyone
else is doing it.
We're turning it into
a standard.
And there are people who
implement it because it's good
for the users.
And there are people who
implement it because they like
to be seen as conforming
to standards.
And the more pressure we apply
by allowing more of these
check boxes to be applied,
the better.
IVAN ZUZAK: So are there any
other tools that are going to
get standardized?
I saw the charter, and you
have Console API from
Developer Tools.
Is that going to happen soon?
PAUL IRISH: So there's
a Java spec for
standardizing Console API.
Mostly, it just needs
more work.
But right now, actually, Console
API is extremely
consistent across browsers.
There's a bunch of different
features in console.log that
most people don't know about
that are actually implemented
across browsers.
Just last summer, we changed the
definition of the dollar
sign symbol in the command
line API in the console.
And while it's not in any
standard, we just talked to
the guys who make Firebug, the
Firefox developer tools, the
Opera guys, and we all just
changed it at once.
So these things stay in sync
pretty well without the
standard being published.
Yeah.
SIMON STEWART: There is a
Browser Tools and Testing
Working Group.
If anyone's interested, they
should think about
joining at the W3C.
And I think there's some efforts
to actually kick start
that and give it some
shape and form.
You may know a bit more about
that, Paul, than I do.
Yeah, OK.
There's an effort, and I'm not
quite sure how far it's gone.
But it'll happen.
REMY SHARP: The debugger
protocol, is that part of the
standard, or is it just that
it's been written and looks
like a standard?
PAUL IRISH: The debugger
protocol--
IVAN ZUZAK: We're talking
about which protocol?
SIMON STEWART: Whose debugger
protocol is that?
Scope or the Firefox one
or the WebKit one?
REMY SHARP: The one that came
out of WebKit that--
like I said, it looked like
a standard Scope.
Looked like it came
from Opera.
The debugger protocol looked
like Chrome and Safari were
kind of adhering to it.
And--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL IRISH: Yeah,
so both are--
REMY SHARP: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Both are published
open specifications and both
designed for use in a
generalized fashion.
I think Firefox was the
last one to add
support for remote debugging.
And they didn't use either
of these two protocols.
So I don't expect to see
standardization along these
lines, which is a bummer,
but it's just how it is.
SIMON STEWART: Not yet.
PAUL IRISH: Not yet.
IVAN ZUZAK: So we have time
for a few questions.
Andrew?
So let's get one in.
What's the best way to test
against varying network
conditions in real life?
We have devices that are
constantly changing, network
switching between
speeds and such.
So how do you test this?
PAUL IRISH: There's two ways,
the two best ways I know.
There's Charles Proxy.
It runs on all platforms.
Can simulate a lot of different
network conditions,
including packet loss and
throttled bandwidth.
And anyone on Lion or better on
OSX, if they install Xcode,
they can get this thing called
Link Conditioner, which is
just in System Preferences.
And it has a few presets for
packet loss percentage and
bandwidth throughput.
But you can mimic a few
different common profiles,
which are pretty cool.
REMY SHARP: Can I also
add something there?
Something I've noticed is that
the iPhone behaves differently
when it has a Wi-Fi connection,
regardless of
whether or not it's on 3G, as
in tethered, to when it
doesn't have a Wi-Fi.
It does different things.
IOS 6 has the Network
Conditioner thing on the
actual device, as well, so you
can play around with that.
But seeing real network
traffic when
you're not on Wi-Fi--
the phone acts differently when
it's on Wi-Fi to when
it's not on Wi-Fi.
When it's on Wi-Fi, it
sends shitloads of
data over the wire.
And I found an article this
morning and tweeted the link
to show you how to sniff traffic
whilst it's on 3G,
connecting through a USB.
But it's something to be
wary of, basically.
IVAN ZUZAK: Great.
So can we get native support
for proxy events?
So--
oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Just one additional
question, then.
Testing things like app cache
and simulating offline whilst
remote debugging.
Is it possible?
We try blacklisting domains in
Charles, and that kind of half
simulates it but not totally.
PAUL IRISH: Not yet.
SIMON STEWART: Yeah, in
lots of the WebDriver
implementations, there's an
expectation there's a working
network stack.
And if you go offline,
that disappears.
D'oh.
AUDIENCE: Offline, we shut
down the server.
That's how we--
I mean, we're not
emulating it.
We're just killing the
server that it's
trying to connect to.
So it kind of fakes it.
IVAN ZUZAK: So here's
one for Remy.
Can we get native support for
proxy events in Dev Tools
injecting geolocation based
on Google Maps inputs?
REMY SHARP: We kind of touched
on that earlier, didn't we?
IVAN ZUZAK: OK.
REMY SHARP: I mean, you can
answer, Paul, if you want to.
IVAN ZUZAK: So here's
one for you, Remy.
You had a recent blog post
that touched upon CORS.
So the headers views to get
across the main [INAUDIBLE]
requests.
And there was a lengthy
discussion after that post.
And can you explain what the
discussion was about?
REMY SHARP: The discussion on
Google+ or the discussion on
the comments?
IVAN ZUZAK: The discussion that
touched upon that we're
not sure, actually, how to
use CORS headers on which
[INAUDIBLE].
REMY SHARP: Who asked
the question?
Because you might be able
to clarify it for me.
IVAN ZUZAK: So it was actually
my question.
REMY SHARP: That was
your question.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
IVAN ZUZAK: Your
last blog post.
So it started quite a discussion
about when to use
CORS on images.
REMY SHARP: Oh yeah, I
basically said, just
turn that shit on.
And I linked to--
I'm going to butcher
his name--
Anne van Kesteren.
So he's got a blog post that
says turn CORS on for XHR, for
basically Ajax.
And I'm suggesting if you're
a Flickr or Instagram or
something with images, and I
think, actually, there's some
other asset types, you should
turn on CORS support for that.
So send, access origin, star.
There's a link at the bottom of
the blog post that opens a
discussion about the security
implications if
you add a star rule.
And there's a back and
forth between Anne
and Malte from Google.
I don't really know how it
ended, but I want to see
these, particularly image
services, giving us
cross-origin rules to allow us
to import that data into
things like Canvas and have full
access to that data so we
can remix the image data and
produce new content.
I can't remember-- there's
something else you can put it
on as well.
PAUL IRISH: If you're really
lazy, just add the Apache
config that's in HTML5
boilerplate, because it
enables this CORS for images
automatically.
IVAN ZUZAK: So do you think that
it's a place where tools
can improve to give you more
information on how you should
use a mechanism or an API?
Because there was a lot of
misunderstanding on, should
you be doing this?
Is it secure?
Is it not secure?
Are we doing [INAUDIBLE]
requests or not?
So like when you're writing
code, should you get a warning
from your IDE and say, hey look,
this is something you
probably are not an expert in.
Check these sections in the
standard, or check this--
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, I think
there's a lot of opportunity
for providing them a bit more
context of what you're seeing.
If you're looking at the
headers, and you're misusing
one of the new security headers,
the tool should be
able to let you know and tell
you where you can find more
documentation on how to
use it correctly.
Same situation on performance,
when you're getting back a lot
of information, it can give
you some guidance and some
resources to learn better
about what this means.
IVAN ZUZAK: Yeah.
OK, that's it.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]